how do you manage your time as
entrepreneurs we are overworked we are
burning from doing everything from the
janitor and our business up to the CEO
we're working 80 to 100 hours a week
we're not sure if we're even working on
the right thing half of the time and
that's the struggle of being an
entrepreneur and and we want our
business to take off and it's not
happening fast enough and we're not
seeing the results we're not seeing the
momentum and it starts to crush us and
we start thinking about is this worth
doing and why am i killing myself well
I'm not seeing any returns what's the
point maybe I should just go back and
get a job and that's that's a process
that almost every entrepreneur goes
through and so managing your time to
focus on the right things is really
important I got a question from a
YouTube viewer I love you guys mohamad
hey Ivan really appreciate what you're
doing could you share further details on
time management it'd be really really
beneficial share so Muhammad I have a
lot to say on time management I have a
whole section of worksheets on it there
are five different worksheets to go
through on how I manage my time and it
started from me not being able to manage
my time and me feeling overwhelmed and
struggling and just feeling like I'm
putting in so much work and pouring
everything I have into this company and
I'm not seeing the results and what the
heck am i doing at the core I have a lot
the same time manager but this is one
short YouTube video at the core of my
philosophy on time management is making
sure that you're spending your time
doing the right thing for your business
when I'm on my way to work every day I'm
thinking what's the best use of my time
today what should I be spending my time
on today that is really the best use
that's really going to help drive my
business forward and the rest you can
either eliminate there's a lot of stuff
you're doing that you shouldn't be doing
at all like your business should not be
doing it's not adding value eliminate
you can automate anything that I do more
than once I try to automate I try to
create a system for it try to automate
the technology as much as possible and
three delegate find somebody else to do
this thing
because you're not great at it and you
don't want to be great at and you want
to do something else you want to add
more value in another department and
delegating doesn't have to be scary and
costly at the start the first person I
hired was for one hour a day one hour a
day to do database entry from my
business so I could not have to do that
and I could spend my one hour a little
bit more because he did it faster than I
did to do other things to grow my
business and you can work up to hiring
somebody for two hours a day and then
five hours a day and then a full-time
person and then another person and
another person that can grow as you
start seeing results but the results
will come when you are spending your
time on what you're really good at to
help build your business forward in the
worksheets I share exactly how I do it
all the steps kind of walk you through
step by step how to do but each one
would take me like two hours sit down
with you and go through how to do it so
it's better to do it on the worksheets
but you have a specific question let me
know I'd be happy to do an answer for
you I know it's a huge area that that we
all struggle with with in managing our
time as an entrepreneur and it took me a
while to figure it out took a while to
kind of crack the code because it goes
against every norm that you're used to
if you're going through school and
getting the job how you talk to manage
your time doesn't work when you are
being an entrepreneur and you're
following your passion you need to allow
time for creativity and need to have
time to focus on the big things with
your company so I hope that helped again
if you have a specific question let me
know be happy to answer it for those of
you watching like this video please give
it a thumbs up below it always makes me
want to do more for you and if you have
a question leave it below I'll make a
video response I love answering your
questions it's the best part of my week
so thank you so much and I'll see you
soon
you